hi there today we'll look at other
aggressive diffusion models by emil
hoggerboom and others of google research
this paper on a high level proposes a
new type of autoregressive model
specifically one where variables can be
decoded in arbitrary orders
this is akin to the new types of
diffusion models that have been used for
generative models and it essentially
amounts to something like bert in
sequence
the training objective is made such that
we can decode variables as we like and i
can show you the results the results are
going to be that we can for example
sample pictures pixel by pixel
in order to make a generative model so
rather than
gans which produce pictures all at once
or
what we had so far auto regressive
models but with a fixed order from for
example from left to right
now we can do it in any order in
addition to this they introduce
techniques where you don't have to go
pixel by pixel but you can do multiple
pixels at the same time and
speed up by a lot
so this is
a paper which is also community informed
so this is a community informed
pay-per-view which means that in
on our discord server we have regular
paper discussions this was one of them i
tried to pay attention i i don't i can't
say yet whether that has worked but i'm
trying to try to recount here a little
bit also so my opinions are influenced a
lot by what was said at the paper
discussion
if you want to influence my opinion uh
feel free to join our paper discussions
okay
so
there
we go
they say they introduced these auto
aggressive diffusion models which is a
model class encompassing and
generalizing order agnostic auto
aggressive models um and absorbing
discrete diffusion models
which they show are special cases yada
yada
they say they're simple to implement and
easy to train unlike standard other
aggressive models which you might know
as um
lstms or standard or regressive models
or gpt type transformers these are all
autoregressive models
they do not require causal masking of
model representations and can be trained
using an effective objective similar to
modern probabilistic diffusion models
that scales favorably to high
dimensional data
at test time the ardms support parallel
generation which can be adapted to fit
any given generation budget so you can
trade off uh how long you need to
produce a given sample with how with the
quality
so you can say i want it faster and
you'll still get a sample you'll just
get a like a lower quality sample
we find that they require significantly
fewer steps than discrete diffusion
models to attain the same performance
yada yada they also do lossless
compression with it okay so what's the
deal with autoregressive models right if
i want to if i have a bunch of variables
let's say i have a piece of text or
something like this uh what i'd have to
do is i'd you know what you'd usually do
in gpt you give a prefix and then you
decode
a token by token from left to right
right a cat and then the model has to
predict sat
on
the
and so on so you predict from left to
right one by one that's also how you
train right you train from left to right
you predict from left to right and with
text that makes kind of sense because we
also read from left to right right
however it would also make sense to do
this in a different order so if you have
a cat
and you
first decode let's say
matt right here
then if you first do that then it
becomes pretty clear what's in here so
in order to give the model sort of the
the biggest freedom you could let it
decode in other places first and then it
could decode the matte here first which
would sort of determine the rest of the
sentence whereas on the top uh the model
already sort of has to have in mind what
it wants to say later like the fact that
that there's matt here
in order to produce all of these things
here
uh
but in in this way uh the model could
predict that first and then the rest is
sort of determined so it could impute
that a little bit
and
this all of this is just to show you
that it's not the only way to decode
left to right and even more so in
something like image gpt so you have an
image and in again i produce the whole
picture as one at once but in something
like image gtp
uh what i do is i start at the top left
and i simply start producing the pixels
left to right
top to bottom right that's it
and
there is not really a reason why this is
the best order to produce things at it's
simply that we train in this way and
that means we have to predict in this
way
what the other aggressive diffusion
models do is they say we're going to
train a model
that can produce a sample in any order
it doesn't matter which one so we could
start off with like this pixel then go
to this and ask for this then ask for
this we can even ask the model something
like which one do you feel best about
like which one are you most sure about
and the model can tell us and then
that's the one that we could we could
decode further we can also tell the
model to decode like three pixels at a
time and then these three pixels and so
on so that's the trade-off i mentioned
so this is how it looks in practice what
you're going to have is you're going to
have a um
a neural
so here the vector is your sample right
and usually you would decode top to
bottom that's sort of the analogous to
left to right that's what you usually
would do however in this model you can
see first it's empty so nothing is
decoded yet you have your neural network
you have your predictor let's say that
predicts a distribution
so for every single item in the sample
it predicts um a distribution so these
here are categorical variables
uh
so it's going to be predicting a
distribution
and
so
all of these for example if the ears are
pixels all of them predict a color so
prediction is made for the whole image
and not just for the thing you want to
decode
and after that you decide on one of them
that you actually want to decode you
sample that or you take the maximum
class or whatever
and then you continue right then the
next step so in the next step you have
the same sample
except that one of the values is now
already decoded the other ones are still
empty again you use a neural network to
predict a distribution for the entire
image you'll see that you know for
technical reasons even this here is
actually predicted it doesn't need to be
but
the important part is that you're going
to predict the entire image at once
and then
you decide to again decode one of them
that's you're choosing
so this one and you can see that you
know this how this goes on
specifically which ones you deco decode
is given by a by this thing right here
this sigma is a
variable that stands for a given
permutation so what you do is if before
before you sample you can select a
permutation you can say here is the
the order in which i want to decode and
then you decode according to that but it
in my mind it doesn't matter even if you
decide on the fly so you can decide on
the fly you know here is here's my
desired order i want to decode in that
way
now if this is seems familiar to you if
you have seen a model something like
this already before then if you're
thinking of bert you would be sort of
correct so even the paper says that this
is kind of like
you take the bert model and you just
kind of stack it um or you just repeat
it notice the
this here
these are always the same neural network
so the same neural network will predict
every single step right here um
that's why it's an autoregressive model
right because you input the output into
the same neural network again so what do
you do in bird you have a bunch you have
a sentence right a cat sat
on
if you do masked language modeling you
put that through the neural network
right that's burt
and out comes one
sort of output per token
now what you do when you train bert you
mask some of the tokens right for
example this one and this one
and then bert predicts these verb
predicts these at once this one and this
one and
what you want to do
sorry bird predicts these tokens at once
and that's a categorical distribution
that's a classification into your
vocabulary right which word was masked
right here so what needs to do is part
needs to infer from the words that exist
uh what other words could be here
notice one interesting property about
bird the question is of course you know
why do we even have to do this in a
particular order can't we just if we are
already predicting all pixels at once
right the network already for each pixel
that's not yet there predicts a
categorical distribution why can't we
just sample that right and the answer is
because these things are not independent
so if
i
um
if i simply
if i have a bunch of variables right
here let me
use this one
if every single one of these nodes
gives me a distribution or let's say
just the ones that are not
just the ones that are not filled out
yet right here i have two pixels or two
elements that are not filled yet
now i'm going to take my input vector
and i'm going to use that to predict for
every of one of these two pixels
what's the distribution of values that
could be there right so the distribution
of values could be well the first the
number one is really popular
to not so much number three a little bit
and here it could be let's say
number one also popular
number two a little bit number three not
that much right
now if if those two are independent then
we could totally
fill these in at the same time but they
might not be right pixels typically
aren't independent if they're in the
same image for example right if the
entire
if the pixel here
is blue that
makes it makes
it's not independent of the fact of
whether the pixel you know right next to
it is blue and that doesn't only count
for pixels next to one another uh that
counts for pixels further away of course
the further they are the less dependent
they probably are but still i can't just
sample both independently i need to
in order to sample
one i need to know what the other is so
i need to sample this one first and not
just have the distribution i need to
commit to one of the
outcomes before i even
try to sample the other one and by
committing to one that will actually
change the distribution of the other one
because this here assumes that
the other pixel will be
according to this distribution however
once it's sampled it's no longer this
distribution it's actually one of these
things for sure like it's maybe this one
for sure if that has been sampled
and that will change in turn the
distribution so what i want to do is i
want to put the whole thing through the
neural network again in order to really
get the true distribution of this node
right here
so maybe
it's maybe it was really likely that
number
class number one was it but now that it
sees well this other node really has
chosen number one so i'm probably not
number one
so i am
class number two maybe
i hope this is re this is a bit clear
that even though we can train in bert
style so we can predict all the things
that are missing at once what we cannot
do is we cannot decode
all the things at once because
what some of the elements or all of the
elements are dependent uh
on all of the other elements and being
dependent means that we they need to
know what the other elements are
before they themselves commit to one of
the classes of their distribution
and
that's the whole the whole point of it
the point is
these models they train like bird
but they decode like
like auto regressive models except that
the order
isn't fixed the order can be any order
you want
and
they do actually apply this to text so
just so you can see
that uh this
how this looks so here's how it looks
this is a character level language model
right so
the uh
it starts off with a relatively empty uh
empty
sentence let's say so the underscores
are just empty these are variables that
are not chosen yet and then it's gonna
fill in a bunch uh at the beginning you
can see that right here and it's gonna
fill in some more right so here it's
gonna fill in some more you'll notice
that all of the ones that existed they
should still exist do they
do they
i'm not even sure like
here the x still exists
the i
still exists this i still exist yeah
okay so all of the ones that were there
they are still there but they're just
more now
and then more are imputed more are
imputed uh until
you finally come to the fully imputed
sentence and um you can see that these
are actual samples from their model so
on text on character level text it's not
yet like super good um
the sentence doesn't really make sense
uh i don't think that's actually an
english word it sounds english but it
may not exactly be an english word a
potentially unsucked proof
or inject operational weapons
in the game car us individual model
so yeah this is it's unclear because
these are the sort of the beginnings of
these types of models of whether that's
the case or whether it's just
much much much more
a much better objective to just train
other aggressive from left to right
because there's also trade-offs right if
you predict every single thing at once
in your loss function has to split
between all the things that there are to
predict
however if you just train left to right
then your loss function can focus fully
on what the next token is right in the
given order so you gain the ability to
decode in any order you want
but that has a trade-off namely a
performance trade-off because the model
that specializes in one particular um in
one particular order will always beat
you so let's go back and i think that's
you know that's the the entire point
i've sort of found you can simplify this
relatively much by essentially saying
you know this is bird training
but you decode one after another and
you can i'm pretty sure
the way this
this is you can you could take
you could take the pre-trained bird
checkpoints and sort of decode
like this
however the problem is of course these
birds checkpoints they have been trained
with like a fixed percentage of um
tokens masked out so they usually say
it's like 10 to 20 percent
of tokens masked out however in order to
really get these models to produce
samples they also have had to have seen
cases where
like this case where zero
sorry not zero one hundred percent of
the tokens are masked right
so the way you train this is you mask
tokens like bert and then you predict
all of them at once
um so the model would have to have seen
every single proportion of masked tokens
so that's not what exactly what um
what bird is trained for but in essence
you could do it
so what's the background the background
is essentially that
these models what they usually do is
they say
look uh the whole sample has a given
probability i can decompose that
probability due to the multiplicative
rule into products or in the log space
sums of probabilities
and this here this part here is what the
order aggressive models take
they say look
if i have a bunch of nodes then the
probability of for example this node
is
conditioned on everything that's before
so i can factorize this into products
where
every probability is conditioned on the
ones before
and these models they essentially go and
they say well there there's no reason no
particular reason why you have to
factorize in this way you can in fact
factorize in any order that you want and
if you do that if you recognize that you
can factorize in any order you want you
can also say that
you can also say that the
you can essentially not only train in
the order
that you decode in
you can already train for all the orders
at once right so if
if my chosen order is i go from here
to here
to here to here right
once i'm at the purple node right in
this particular order i would go here
next
but
in many other orders right where i came
from from here
in other order i would go here next and
in yet another order i could choose i
would go here next and these orders i
sample uniformly okay so i can
reasonably assume that the next time i
see the sample i'm in one of those other
orderings
and therefore the expectation of my loss
function is just the average if i were
to predict this one or this one or this
one at this time
and therefore
if why do i have to wait for the next
samples uh i can simply say right now
well i'm simply going to predict all of
them at the same time and then take the
mean as my loss function so the mean
classification error as my loss function
rather than just predict the one in the
order where i happen to be
left to right models don't need to do
that because they are always left to
right so the next time they see the
sample
they will have to only decode the exact
same next variable however these models
we train them to
work in arbitrary orders and therefore
we might as well predict all of the
orders at once and take the mean of the
loss function as a loss function and
there again you see the trade-off
this allows us then to decode in any
order we want however also there's a
trade-off now only one over the number
of of remaining nodes uh is the portion
of the loss function that is really
trained on the order that we're
eventually going to have and all the
others are essentially
superfluous well they might help for
generalization a bit but you know
the
you you significantly reduce loss mass
on the order that you actually then care
about at the end when you sample
here's how you sample it's pretty simple
it's what i said so you initialize x
empty you sample one order as i said you
don't have to commit to one at the
beginning but that's how you specified
you sample an order uniformly um
then you go through the
through the ordering through the
permutation here sigma is the the
permutation of the node's decode
this is he's very complicated written so
the they built these masks right here
you can see they built these masks and
essentially m is just whatever has been
decoded so far n is whatever is whatever
one node is to pre predict it right now
uh
so what you do is you build a
categorical distribution
um
you put
the masked x into your neural network
built a categorical distribution so this
here means
you'd predict
all of the
nodes at once given what you've
predicted so far so m times x is what
you've predicted so far that goes into a
neural network that's essentially the
learned part of this and the neural
network will output a distribution a
categorical distribution for every
single other node there is
and what you do then is you choose the
one the n you know that's the entry in
the um ordering that you chose you
choose the one that you want to decode
and
you simply augment amend the sample
that
you have by the one you want to decode
this is written very complicated in a
very complicated way
so
optimizing training these models isn't
too hard either
what you're going to do is you have a
data point that i guess you sample from
the data
set
you're going to sample one particular
time step so notice here we go over all
the time steps because we actually want
to get a sample when we train that's
much like
uh transformer other regressive models
actually there we can train all the time
steps at once but the individual
training sample
is just we select one particular time
step
in one particular ordering right so we
select an ordering and in that ordering
we select the time step
um
and typically what you do is so you have
a picture you have pixels what this
amounts to is we say
okay we're just gonna mask a bunch of
these pixels right here we're just gonna
black them out right that will
correspond to some time step in some
ordering so we're just going to assume
we have predicted all of the ones that
we haven't masked and now we're trying
to predict all of the ones that we did
mask right all of these ones we're going
to predict at once
and um
yeah that will
so you notice that there is no n right
here
the n specifies the one pixel you want
to predict next but during training we
simply mask out a bunch of pixels
and then we predict all at once so again
we have the m which is what we've
predicted so far we input m times x into
the neural network so the neural network
will predict the distribution of
every single thing that we haven't
predicted so far and rather than
selecting n from it
we now select
1 minus m so everything that hasn't been
predicted so far and then we average
that and that will become our loss
function
okay now given that we know what the
pixels are that we've masked during
training
we can actually compute this loss
function
and you know that's that's it that's how
you train
uh pretty simple as i said this should
remind you of bird
and yeah so they have several extensions
to this which i just briefly wanna touch
so they now they say
well if we if we
sort of allow a bunch of times these
dependence independency mistakes so you
know given that we have like
i don't know a million pixels in an
image right
can't we just sort of assume that you
know the pixel up here and maybe the
pixel here they're kind of independent
from each other so couldn't we just sort
of sample
um
sample them at once so we can sample
multiple pixels at once uh if they're
kind of far away from each other we
we're just kind of fine with that um
and uh
yeah
so we trade off
speed
predicting multiple pixels at a time
by we trade off speed and accuracy
essentially because now the pixels that
we predict at the same time they have no
knowledge of the other pixels in the
same time step
that's the problem we've talked about
before
and then they go a step further and they
say well rather than deciding you know
we want to decode five pixels at a time
instead of just one what we're going to
do is we're going to give the algorithm
a budget
and
they say look you have an entire image
we have 20 steps
so you need to decide
this is the visualization right here you
have 20 steps you need to decide do i
want to go like
um do i want to go
so
here is like one pixel then two pixels
then three pixels then five pixels then
the rest of the pixels right these are
five time steps that's your budget you
decide
so they use a dynamic programming
algorithm
essentially they build up they go
through their as far as i understand it
they go through their training data set
um
they compute
what they call loss components so here
is your your budget and here is the
number of
nodes in
the uh in the
here is the number of nodes
in your data points
and so you can say okay for step number
three
if i were to decode five uh steps in
step number three right how much would
that cost
and then you can try to find in classic
dynamic programming fashion a path
through
this matrix and
you know at the end this path is going
to give you what how many pixels you
should decode at what step so for
example here in step one we decode two
then we decode one
i don't know what this actually means
one no zero
that makes no sense and then we decode
uh the rest
but you know how dynamic programming
works and this isn't this is from a
different paper actually but they just
say you know we can use this given that
we train for any order at all and
predict all at the same time this is an
option so you can technically trade this
off
what they also do is this depth
upscaling
and what they do in the depth of scaling
is they say well
you know if we're trying to predict a
pixel value for a pixel right the pixel
value is like
256 classes that's it's a big thing
right
let's not have the model
so the model needs to sort of commit to
one of them
you know immediately like that's my
pixel value
what if what if we could do the
following what if we could have the
model just predict which half of the
pixel values it's in right are you
bright in the blue channel or are you
not bright are you dark okay and then we
do this for all the pixels so all the
pixels in the image they simply first in
the first iteration decide am i
light or am i dark right am i light am i
dark am i light am i dark and so on and
then once everyone has decided on that
we go over the image again and we say
well okay now okay i should have filled
all of them just imagine all of them
filled in
now they say okay now you pixel who
previously decided you were light now
that you see all the other pixel and
their crude decision you know what sub
part of the light do you fall in are you
very light or just a bit light
and then so we go through the image
multiple times right it can even be in
different orders and the advantage here
is that you first let the other
parts make crude decisions and then you
don't have to decide out of the blue
right so you you know sort of
approximately what all the others are
before you refine and then you refine
refine refine until you get to the final
choice so this is i think this is a neat
idea they specify exactly you know how
to do this however i can't help noticing
that
as you can see the ordering here by
which you decode so you first predict
the
the crude part then the not so crude
part then the not so not so crude part
and finally you predict the the full
part i can't help but notice that this
is again a fixed order auto-aggressive
model right this is this is again like
this is exactly what they're trying to
run away from
uh so they they just introduce it again
in a subpart of their model which i find
to be funny right and on the on the
other hand this this only works really
uh this is my other problem with this
this only works if
this isn't really a categorical variable
right pixel value pixel value is a
continuous variable you can be anywhere
we just discretize it right and that's
why this works the you know decide on
your crude and then go go um more less
and less crude go more and more detailed
if you have something like a true
classification right um let's say into
tokens of a vocabulary like a b c
d e it it makes no sense to ask them
well in which half of the alphabet are
you the model can't do a crude decision
it already needs to know to answer this
question for you so unless you have a
way to really split the vocabulary in
meaningful fashion it this doesn't make
sense this is really this is really a
a workaround around the artifact that
they need categorical variables for
their model and therefore they
discretize the the um
the brightness here of the pixels and
you know that's a result of that
so in any case i don't want to dive too
much into the results you've already
seen them they do don't do large scale
um as far as i can tell they do c410
generation they also do lossless
compression what they can do is with
their model they have a pretty good
handle at the trade-off so this gives
you the apple so the the user of the
model a good way of trading off
uh performance for speed and you can do
this on the fly right you can do
you can say i want less performance i
want more performance i have less of a
budget to infer the sample or more and
you can change from from time to time
and yeah these these models as i said
they're young therefore they have a way
to go uh we've put so much work into
gans and whatnot and and other
aggressive text models that
the fail like the fact that these here
are not state of the art yet they might
it might just be an artifact of that or
they might just suck who knows all right
thank you so much for listening as i
said join our discord to get uh in on
the paper discussions they're usually
very very entertaining
and i'll see you next time bye